when the administration gave its pitch
for coal and nuclear energy at the UN
conference on climate change that's fun
it was disrupted by evil demonstrators
through charm
[Music]
[Applause]
well that's as catchy not as enjoyable
and as surprising is the gas you get
after taco after eating a taco supreme
trying to speak common sense the UN is
like trying to speak Chinese to a table
lamp and anything positive you say is
going to get booed the UN prefers
dictators and socialism if you want that
UN to cheer you promote failure and
death their hatred for industries be it
nuclear or coal is imbedded in their
hatred ultimately for capitalism even as
we rid the world of it's truly worst
threat which is Isis they still hate us
for trying but what can you expect from
these climate deniers that's what these
protesters are climate deniers they
refused to believe the climate has
changed one to sober analysis and fact
here's what they deny that coal would
save millions of lives in poor countries
by replacing the toxic impure fuels they
use and that the Paris of course was a
terrible deal that would have also cost
lives you want to spend a hundred
trillion to capture a fraction of a
degree Celsius research shows that less
than half that cash could rid the world
of poverty hunger disease and pollution
using that cash carelessly is homicidal
which could be why the UN is in love
with it
by the way Syria just joined the Paris
Accords now by the UN's logic that
country is far more compassionate than
us so what if you gas your own people at
least that drives down the carbon
footprint
it is terrible I love a Kimberly how
those protesters because they're
ignorant they're ignorant they're
accusing those people in the podium of
murder when they do if they deny Cole
the third world nations two to three
million according to the Copenhagen
consensus to 2.8 billion people used
mostly wood and dung dung to cook and
keep warm
that kills 2.8 million people each year
from indoor air pollution if you replace
that with coal you would save 3 million
people's lives these people are the
murderers okay so they're accessories to
crime I'm just doing what they do right
so they're accessories today yeah yep
genocide essentially is what you're
saying well I mean but that's why you
have to arm yourself with the facts and
and understand the issues very clearly
on this there you know I mean look at
least they're not anti foul they're sort
of singing in weird outfits or like
stabbing you know horses or whatever but
nevertheless they're trying to unite and
be expressive about an issue that they
care about but perhaps they're not as
fully informed as they could be this is
the problem so I don't know they've
disrupted this I like the little
bouncing dot you know Danette Buuren
lumber he runs the Copenhagen consensus
center they calculate that for 37 point
5 trillion you could eradicate poverty
hunger disease around the world around
the world fix climate change pollution
all that stuff by 20 I think it's by
2030 30 yes so if you don't do that and
you follow the climate Accords
100 trillion over over one to two
trillion a year you killed those people
it actually makes financial sense this
is a case that President Trump could
make pretty persuasively if you wanted
to give a speech about climate change in
energy somebody like him to do what
you're saying when you were you know
when you were saying that they're the
accessory to the murder yeah like
actually why doesn't people with common
sense actually do that because we're
nice we have for too long and actually
technological innovation is one of the
things that they were talking about
there was how you can take because we're
going to deal with coal for a long time
how can you have technological
innovation developed here in the United
States
address the issue of coal make it
cleaner so that people can have
the energy that they need so that we can
develop even better more renewable
energies one why do you hate poor people
well if you really cared about poor
people from third world nations mr.
lecturer over here you would you would
understand that in fact in the Paris
climate deal
there were concessions made to third
world countries to allow them to
continue using coal and natural gas and
that it was the United States as a world
leader that said we're going to set an
example in terms of cutting back because
we want you to cut back as you grow as
you be as you get a larger middle class
in places like China and Brazil so
that's why we were in the deal which is
now going forward again yesterday which
area yeah
now last then that means we're the only
country not in the deals were cool oh
yeah that's it well actually we're warm
because we have cold but I would say
this to your point that you have people
over there like Al Gore I know you don't
like Al Gore yeah yeah and you have our
former Mayor Michael Bloomberg right
Michael Bloomberg had a great quote
about this because I agree with Dana by
the way that date the Trump people had a
legitimate point to make about the
efficient use of coal and natural gas
and saying hey was going to be used
let's think about it but then you have
the reality that people perceive them as
such enemies such so angry at the heat
at the idea of trying to limit
greenhouse gases that you have Michael
Bloomberg say promoting coal at the
climate summit is like promoting tobacco
at a cancer summit that gives you an
idea of how we are perceived now right
that's by our own I can't help our
perceptions Jesse and neither can you
know imagine that's true imagine if
you're the parent and you've just spent
two hundred thousand dollars on your
daughter to go to college probably
Middlebury or somewhere like that and
you said what'd you do this weekend
Candice and she said I protested a cold
conference at the UN you got to think to
yourself that was not money well spent
and these people probably went to very
nice schools want to put coal miners in
West Virginia out of work that's what
they're doing
oh and of all it's true one of their
Hillary oh yeah that's why their doors
are heated by coal yeah because if you
don't have coal you don't have jobs in
West Virginia
like that we don't have any jobs coming
from losing we don't have any other
thing that's I'm pretty funny too is
that maybe Solyndra how many jobs were
there yeah Oh a job I can still count
them on my fingers okay and think about
of all the tyrants and dictators and
human rights abusers at the United
Nations these people decided to protest
America I know
we've about we America with others have
destroyed Isis if we were saving
people's lives and these people are
protesting as it's disgusting what about
Lee Greenwood song right I think they
did a nice render yeah that's what I
thought I thought part of the whole
protest all right